-10 seconds to video!
In five...
To video, 3, 2...
♪♪♪♪
-Guests are the lifeblood
of a talk show.
You know, we need them
to keep going.
So we've been Zooming,
and that's amazing.
We were so happy with that
But to have a guest in studi
is a game changer.
When we first had
Gaten Matarazzo on the show,
it was literally they were
the kids from "Stranger Things."
They were kids.
They were children.
He's always, again,
someone I just look forwar
to talking to him
and seeing what he's up to
And he tells me about new things
that I don't know about.
There are, like, toddlers
who love "Stranger Things,
who are just --
Yeah, they think
it's like the bomb-dot-com
[ Laughter ]
But it's a little scary.
-It's a little scary.
-Yeah. For a 3-year-old.
-Sometimes, like --
It's like people
who don't speak,
like, most words will look at me
and just be like, "Dustin.
It was really cool
to be back in the studio.
I'm glad it's not as quiet
as it has been
the past couple of months,
and it's really cool
to have people there.
The energy's always great,
and it feels like the old show
♪♪♪♪
-Michael Strahan's been a
friend of ours for a long time
He's always there and always
down to do something different
something weird,
something fun.
This last time, we played
game, and he just crushed me
I'm gonna need a competito
worthy of the golf pong course
so, ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome the one
and only Michael Strahan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
No.
Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Every time I see Kevin Bacon
coming up on the calendar,
I get excited.
He's so talented.
He can -- He can act,
he can sing, and he can play
-We are going to do anothe
edition of First Drafts of Rock.
And I think this is
maybe our eighth or ninth time
It's just this goofy thing tha
we've been doing for years that,
you know, I've been so lucky
to have been asked
to be part of it
'cause I got to sing
and put on a wig,
and have a good time.
We're doing The Allman Brothers,
"Ramblin' Man."
-Let's make it all about
how he was born
in the back of a Greyhound bus
in the first drafts
of the song.
So the band just playing,
and then he's singing,
and then he's like,
"Sorry. I'm sorry.
Just to go back for a second
you said you were born
on a bus?"
These are rad.
-Awesome.
-So you just drew this up,
and then...?
-Yep.
-Fantastic, buddy.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Be funny if I just
kind of hopped up and down
That's not how
he plays at all, but...
[ Laughter ]
-...its first draft until now.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ I knew you were born
a ramblin' man ♪♪
♪♪ But I didn't know about
the bus birth till just now
-The more he gets to come in
the more bits we can do
with the guests,
and, you know,
just the show will
just keep getting bigger
and trying new things.
That's the next step.
♪♪♪♪
Kevin Bacon, everybody!
Kevin Bacon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you
do it right there.
♪♪♪♪
I got my start in stand-up
and that's my roots.
It's emotional, in a weird way
to have stand-up back,
because it means so much to me
but also means so much
to New York City.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's go!
How you guys doing tonight
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Shout-out to New York City.
We're coming back, baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're gonna make it.
-Thank you guys so much.
I'm Mary Beth.
-Emmy Blotnick
was perfect to come back
and perform
in front of an audience.
To see her get those laughs,
it's electric, it's exciting
-I wish when I was a kid,
there'd been
a Sleep Disorder Barbie.
You know, just to get
the image in your head, right?
Just to see little girls
being like,
"My Barbie likes melatonin!"
[ Laughter ]
"My Barbie smokes weed
till she's tired."
[ Laughter ]
"Whoa! Ken sleeps
in a separate bedroom!"
[ Laughter ]
Thank you guys so much.
I'm Emmy Blotnick.
It's an electric thing.
It's so amazing.
'Cause during the pandemic
I got
used to doing shows on Zoom.
-It's another piece
to the puzzle.
And it's been a tough year -
more than a year.
And it's -- I can see
that we're gonna come back
♪♪♪♪